ser maxi válido y sabía que ese es el
título cierto no ser maxival no sabían
yo soy máximo herido ser maxival yo es
un estilo de vida miren beethoven
'miguel de cervantes' vincent van gogh
franklin delano roosevelt stephen
hawking christopher reeve
helen keller nick vujicic y además demo
se han visto buscando a nemo no demo
nace con una diferencia y ser diferente
es normal es normal ser diferente cuando
digo yo que es un estilo de vida es
porque cada uno de ellos tomó la
decisión de transformar su vida
y de pasadita que hicieron transformaron
el mundo frida kahlo artista mexicana
tiene una frase que es absolutamente
inspiradora dice pies para que los
quiero
si tengo alas para volar esto va más
allá del pensamiento cierto y la
voluntad se abre volar a mí me encanta
yo soy como un chiquito en un avión tomó
fotografías de los cielos azules desde
la cabina era avión pero lo más
importante de volar que es poder
aterrizar y tú necesitas un tren de
aterrizaje y adivine que tiene tren de
aterrizaje
ruedas la rueda fue un gran invento del
diseño universal y para estoy hablando
de ruedas pues traigo a este gran amigo
mío que me acompaña durante mucho tiempo
él se llama pp cariñosamente pp porque
porque es que mucha gente le dice de
otra manera y yo quisiera saber usted
cómo le dice usted sabe quién soy yo
usted sabe quién soy yo qué símbolo es
eso que el símbolo representa este
muchacho es capaz y en colombia nos
dicen sí en colombia nos dicen que este
es el símbolo de la discapacidad oiga
increíble venga les presento en la
realidad de pepe mentiras caigan de esa
nube no es el símbolo de la discapacidad
es el símbolo internacional de la
accesibilidad y hemos estado 50 años
diciendo que esto es discapacidad no es
cierto hizo siete mil uno y colombia
adopta el símbolo con la norma técnica
colombiana de nfc 41 39 entonces pp nos
ha cambiado también mucho porque nos
está mostrando una especie
también la etiqueta que pp tiene un
primo ya me muere pipe y en eeuu la
alcaldía de nueva york cierto a través
de su oficina una oficina accesible'
icon project
sandra servent diseña algo similar para
decir que nueva york está accesible o
algunos entornos son accesibles
entonces yo comienzo a entender que pipe
está en una posición aerodinámica cierto
y se nota que es autónomo sexy puede
mover fácilmente por sus propios medios
pero sigue siendo pp son pictogramas que
son reconocidos por 7.500 millones de
humanos en este planeta y eso número 5
pictogramas más reconocidos y se
reconoce es como discapacidad cierto
naciones unidas en el año 2015 dice se
acabó la guachafita se acabó el festín
como así que las etiquetas que el
estacionamiento exclusivo para
discapacitados baño exclusivo para
discapacitados y miren lo chévere
gustemos centro comercial cierto y
encuentra baño de damas baño de hombres
y encuentra pp estamparán otra pared o
sea que nosotros somos el tercer género
esto era por tomarle el pelo y para
sacarlos de sus hijos
pero no es no no vamos tan allá pero
simplemente tú no entras al baño de pepe
porque es que es el baño los
discapacitados no te estaciones en el
estacionamiento de pepe porque ese
estacionamiento los discapacitados y es
más no voy a decir honestamente díganme
cuántos de ustedes se sientan en la
silla azul de trasmilenio cuando está
desocupada yo también años y ella no lo
piensa en tres veces yo no es que la
silla los discapacitados esas sillas
para usted también porque es que resulta
que el símbolo esa accesibilidad que
universal y naciones unida dijo se acabó
la guachafita y vamos a lanzar al primo
de pepe y pipe ponga música y paco bajo
está inspirado en vitruvio pues creo yo
eso no lo ha dicho la oficina de diseño
gráfico de naciones unidas cierto pero
leonardo da vinci leonardo en 1490 hizo
un estudio súper chévere basado en
vitruvio el hombre de vitruvio un
arquitecto romano del siglo primero que
establecía las proporciones del cuerpo
humano con referente a su entorno pues
para ccoo es muy similar y pako
identifica al ser humano diverso
bebé infante adolescente adulto persona
mayor y me está diciendo que está
inscrito entre un entorno que está
compuesto por que por espacios por
comunicaciones por objetos y por
servicios es un símbolo neutral es
imparcial y esto nos puede ayudar a
mejorar un poco la interpretación
etiquetas adiós a partir de hoy usted
tiene que hacer un cambio un cambio de
chip y dice no ricardo no es
discapacitado ave ni minusválido
minusválido
yo quiero que usted comiencen a conectar
el concepto minus marido término
peyorativo máximo ario que significará
ser maxival yo le dije que era un estilo
de vida vamos a ver qué se trata ahora
etiquetas adiós 0 porque porque yo no
soy un etiqueta situm etiquetas tú me
niegas la oportunidad de compartir
contigo en igualdad de condiciones en
una fila preferencial en un almacén de
grandes superficies o en un banco yo
llego a la fila donde tú estás vas a
apagar tu mercado y yo me coloco detrás
tuyo y tú me miras así
señor usted que hace en esta fila como
así que qué hago en esta fila a mí me
toca mirar para arriba y para abajo
el señor usted que hace la fila pues que
la suya es allá
como así las jubilaciones allá que es la
fina de los discapacitados la fila
preferencial a partir de hoy el concepto
preferencial lo vamos a entender como
algo excluyente ciertamente lo que pasó
la persona me sacó de ahí y evitó que yo
compartiera con usted
usted misma mesa con ella yo quería
compartir con usted este nuevo divina
así no se puede
entonces miren las etiquetas no
funcionan yo no soy un adjetivo yo no
soy una cosa transmilenio 5 y 30 de la
tarde bus repleto voy a ser una estación
y la gente muy querida dicen del espacio
la silla de ruedas que va a salir silla
de ruedas será que va con piloto
automático porque está
eso lo va conduciendo un ser humano es
más dele permiso que va a salir un
usuario de silla con ruedas a eso suena
como más digno cierto estos son los
cambios que usted se debe llevar hoy y
enseñárselo a su familia esta noche y
uno se pregunta además cuántos usuarios
de silla con ruedas hay en esta sala
levanten la mano cayeron todos cuantos
usan bicicleta
levante la mano de la bicicleta y rápido
mantengan arriba cuantos usan sillas de
oficina con ruedas
abrieron usamos lo mismo todos somos
usuarios de silla con ruedas en igualdad
de condiciones pero lo manejamos
diferente ahí está el éxito en la máxima
valía como entiende la manera en que yo
hago las cosas no soy circunstancia con
el cuidado esto
hasta ahora pico es divina 5 y 30 de la
tarde estación del virrey autopista
norte costa oriental ya están ahí
listo que pasa 90 personas por minuto
entrando a la estación 90 yo esperé dos
minutos 180 redondeamos en 200 nadie me
ayuda a subir la rampa increíble no ya
después de esos dos minutos dije aquí
hay que hacer la reacción pedagógica
venía un señor 28 30 años y le dice así
la seña me ayuda y saben qué dijo el
señor no tengo me mató
no tengo entendió y me dio a mí como la
discapacidad del mendigo además con esta
pinta esta voz de corbata a ver yo me
regale un empujón rampas de más de 30
metros de recorrido con gradientes
superiores al 14 por ciento el ácido
láctico me come en los primeros 55
metros de recorrido me mata yo no puedo
subir a solo la pregunta es esta rampa
está accesible sí o no
sí sí es accesible porque porque el
señor me pudo haber empujado y nos vamos
subimos y yo llego hasta arriba y así
puedo acceder el problema es que no es
incluyente porque no fomenta mi
autonomía
no todo lo accesible es incluyente pero
todo lo incluyente es accesible muy bien
y no soy circunstancia soy una persona
qué cambio con una condición la
discapacidad como lo establece la
convención sobre derechos de las
personas con discapacidad se evidencia
cuando yo con una deficiencia motriz
interactúo con las barreras que impone
el entorno y que restringen y evitan mi
participación plena mi problema no es
que mis piernas no funcionen como las
tuyas ese no es mi problema mi problema
es como círculo cómo me desplazo cómo
puedo subir una rampa cómo la puedo
bajar de manera segura cómo puedo
entender la información de un autobús
que me está diciendo las paradas y se
queda callado qué vaina ciertos no me
deja dormir ese perifoneo y usted no
sabe que ese perifoneo la persona ciega
es su herramienta para poderse expresar
y nosotros no le estamos entendiendo el
para qué es o qué ruido ese no yo estoy
atrevido y les voy a plantear un
escenario matemático de la autonomía la
autonomía equivale a las barreras que me
impone el entorno por mi capacidad
elevado al cuadrado exponencialmente
hablando vamos a hacer la prueba la
tabla en 0 0 x 1
pero por 20 x 30 por 40 por cinco si tú
le asignas cero a las barreras del
entorno my discapacidad la discapacidad
no está en mí la discapacidad está en el
entorno que me está restringiendo mi
acción pero si tú le asignas un valor
diferente a cero a la barrera cualquiera
que sea leve moderada severa y mi
dificultad funcional puede ser leve
moderada o severa n por n cuanto da en
el cuadrado sea mi capacidad a mí me
toque esforzarme el triple paso y me he
subido a las rampas créanme pero llegó
con la lengua fuera del corazón a mil y
la respiración agitada ustedes
imagínense en una rampa de esas a las
diez y media de la noche antes de que
terminen la circulación de transmilenio
y yo sólo como un champiñón esperando
que me recoge y me toca hacerlo solo es
muy complejo bien discapacidad que es
discapacidad realmente pues yo no sé yo
no voy a meter en esta discusión hay
otras personas más amigas que yo pero yo
lo entiendo así el prefijo dice
generalmente identifica disminución
disminución de la capacidad yo te la
comparto de otra manera yo lo que tengo
es una
quinta capacidad fíjate en lo diferente
cuando tú me ves con disminuido es muy
diferente cuando uno es distinto y qué
es lo que realmente qué es lo que
realmente me hace distinto mi valía y
entramos al concepto la valía según lo
define la real academia española de la
lengua me está diciendo que el valor de
la precio de algo es la calidad de una
persona que vale pero me encanta la
pregunta porque se identifica mucho con
el concepto que yo le estoy proponiendo
esta es ese concepto transformador de
sociedades incluyentes y en la máxima
aliado la mayor valía acrecentamiento de
valor que por circunstancias externas
entorno barreras actitudinales
urbanísticas físicas arquitectónicas
objetores y comunicativas recibe algo
independientemente de cualquier mejora
hecha en ello buenísimo entonces a
inicia el concepto de máxima válidos
el equipo mundial de máx y válidos ya le
mencioné unos cuantos colombia tiene
cientos miles millones de macs y varios
de ellos se lo tienen que creer el maxi
bar ya no es gratuita la maxival ya se
construye quien es un máximo de un ser
humano maxi vario es único es singular
irrepetible no tiene clones
es firme es alegre es creativo y es fiel
y ferviente cree en sí mismo y cree que
puede elaborar un cambio maximiza sus
dones y sus talentos y lo más lindo de
todo es que sigue al pie de la letra el
manual del éxito por allá el manual del
éxito dice amate a ti mismo que ama lo
demás a tu prójimo como a ti mismo si tú
no te amas a ti mismo cómo vas a amar el
resto de personas yo no lo entiendo o
sea tu nivel de autoestima debe estar en
un buen nivel no excesiva de a poco por
debajo el ser humano max y válido es una
persona que autogestiona su proyecto de
vida es una persona que solidaria
resiliente y tolerante es audaz es deja
huella pero ante todo es una persona
feliz
y finalmente un maxi dolido es un ser
humano ordinario que hace cosas
extraordinarias muy bien y ahora la
historia y con esto vamos errando la
historia inicia con esta señora ella se
llama ofelia
y en mi mamá ahí estoy chiquito con unos
seis meses al psoe como meses
esta foto para mí tiene un valor valor
tiene una valía valía increíble porque
fue la última fotografía que me tomaron
caminando a usted esta foto y se le
arruga el cucharón sí o no y después de
este tiempo después de este paseo dio ya
yo me encuentro ya con aparatos
ortopédicos
además ya ver en cómo me declararon
miope entonces el mío take ojo pues él
con vos como bueno e igual para mí no
era importante
yo no tenía esa ese pensamiento ay
pobrecito yo ahí castigo de dios estoy
en un colegio regular como cualquier
otro chino
súper reconocido por varios motivos por
ser nerdo académicamente me fue como
bien 108 compañeros increíbles que
creyeron en ricardo y que finalmente en
su graduación lo premiaron además
condecoraciones en todo mi bachillerato
pero las que más quiero son las dos
últimas medallas porque esa medalla
significa el mejor compañero y eso no me
lo dio ni el rector ni los profesores
que se lo dan mis compañeros
si ha habido eres tú y te vamos a
reconocer astro europeo en el corazón
sigo por la línea jesuita me graduó como
diseñador industrial de la pontificia
universidad javeriana y ya no sé si hago
caso a la falsa modestia pero yo digo
con mucho orgullo que yo me pague mi
carrera en la universidad adriana sé que
si se puede como tienes un talento
tienes un don
explota lo sé máximo al yo y darle las
riendas falta la vida cierto
atravieso el charco móvil para
inglaterra con una gran amiga car en la
que nos ganamos el premio es una
conferencia internacional de diseño
universal y diseño inclusivo entregamos
un premio en el royal collection farc
por la mejora e iniciativa diseño
inclusivo y aquí viene
fcc felizmente casado y les presento a
mi lucha en este proyecto de vida
continúa este año cumplimos 25 años de
casados 28 estar juntos y les presento a
los dos becerros nicolai emanuel los dos
por la línea del diseño diseño de medios
digitales y diseño industrial
hace 4 años hago parte del equipo de
ministerio de transporte asegurando
política pública en accesibilidad y
diseño universal para los sistemas de
transporte la máxima área tú ves y es el
máximo ha habido stones desde todos
nosotros además maxi bario también puede
ser alguien que perdió un familiar una
tulsa alguien que salió de la
drogadicción del alcoholismo se cree que
renace y decide cambiar y así cambiar
también el mundo que fue lo que yo
decidí quitarle el disc a mi capacidad
un ser humano capaz que finalmente se
declara maxi válido incluir es convivir
juntos tú y yo podemos disfrutar el
mundo en el mismo lugar al mismo tiempo
y de distinta manera miren estos tres
señores quienes se josé feliciano y este
señor
stevie wonder y este caballero y que se
parece en los tres levanten la mano y
que digo que era ciego ahí se los pide
yo lo escuché clarificó son cantantes
son exitosos son talentosos los de
ciegos
porque ellos ven de otra manera de
diferente manera son maxi válidos porque
transformaron sus días decidieron es
decidieron hacer el cambio y ahí
simplemente cambiaron el mundo cuál es
el llamado se necesitan maxi válidos que
quieran transformar el mundo en un mundo
mejor para todo el mundo gracias y
cielos azules para ustedes
[Aplausos]